Online dating can be tough, but if you're not meeting anyone,...
...maybe you're just not looking in the right places.
Hey, I'm Gillian on Buzz60.
The Internet is filled with dating websites, but in the midst of the eHarmonies and Match.coms,...
...there are some really specific sites I bet you didn't even know existed...
...like dating sites for farmers: Cowboy Cowgirl is "Where country meets country",...
...and Farmers Only boasts thousands of down-to-earth country folks.
Love to sail?
Try Sea Captain Date.
Or if you're a big fan of horses, check out Equestrian Cupid.
Sometimes it's hard to find someone who can understand your restricted diet,...
...but sites like Singles with Food Allergies and the Vegan Dating Service have you covered.
If you care a lot about looks, ditch the Beautiful People only sites and give Find Your FaceMate a shot.
It makes matches based on similar facial features.
And there is Stache Passions for all the mustache lovers out there.
Or you can try the UglyBugBall.com, dating for the aesthetically average.
So maybe it should be called DatingForTheAestheticallyAverage.com
Just a thought.
Buzz60.
Now you know, pass it on.